Vandaag neem ik je mee in wat chatt zou
zeggen als jij een online inkomen wilt
opzetten in [muziek] 2026. En heel veel
mensen die willen dit alleen ze weten
gewoon niet waar te starten. En daarom
ga ik samen met je chatbt sparren over
hoe je de komende [muziek] 3e maanden
een online inkomen op kunt gaan zetten.
Laten we erin duiken. En zoals je kunt
zien, het is een compleet schoon chatbt
account. Geen andere chats mee gevoerd
[muziek] en dit doe ik puur zodat hij
nog geen vooroordeel heeft over mij.
Want ChatGBT die gaat natuurlijk kennen
wie jij bent. En uiteindelijk kan het
ook een voordeel zijn, want je kan chat
GPT wel vragen van heyé, [muziek] op
basis van mijn vaardigheden die ik al
heb of wat je al kent over mij, geef een
advies welk beste model het beste bij
mij zou kunnen passen. Die vraag zou je
later kunnen stellen, maar bij mij is
het dus een compleet schoon account,
[muziek] zodat ik totaal geen
vooroordeel heb op een bepaald business
model. Dus laten we er lekker induiken.
Het allereerste wat ik ga vragen aan
chatbt [muziek] is als volgt. Geef mij
de top drie business modellen of
sideehustels die ik kan starten naast
mijn baan of studie [muziek]
in 2026.
Ik ben heel benieuwd en ik gebruik
natuurlijk het dicteren, want het is
super handig. JGBT. [muziek]
Ehm ik typ bijna niks meer. Het scheelt
je sowieso heel veel tijd als je heel
veel eh via spraak doet. Dus dat is
sowieso tip nummer één. Als je AI
gebruikt, ga lekker er tegen praten,
want dat helpt gewoon het beste. Oké,
interessant. Kijken wat hij als top 3
zegt. Mijn top drie voor 2026 is op
nummer é AI automatiseringen voor kleine
bedrijven. Oké, interessant. Help
bedrijven herhalende taken automatiseren
met AI, klantervice, e-mail, offertes,
administratie, content of interne
workflows.
Oké. En wat hij er dus bij zegt is: "Nou
ja, startkosten zijn laag. Verdienmodel
eenmalige implementatie plus
maandelijkse vergoeding. De schlbaarheid
is hoog. En waarom interessant? Veel
bedrijven willen AI gebruiken, maar
weten niet hoe ze het praktisch moeten
inzetten. Oké, helder. Klinkt als een
goede niche. En als nummer twee hebben
we een niche service business.
Productiseren. Eens kijken wat hij
daarmee bedoelt. Kies één concreet
probleem en [muziek] verkoop één
duidelijke dienst. Bijvoorbeeld short
form voor makelaars of LinkedIn content
voor consultants of website voor lokale
bedrijven. Interessant. Dus hij wilt
meer richting de content [muziek] kant.
Je kunt beginnen als freelancer en maak
vervolgens processen templates, zodat je
steeds minder uren per klant nodig hebt.
Oké, helder. En als nummer drie,
[muziek] digitale producten of nich
content business. Bouw bijvoorbeeld een
template pakket, [muziek] cursus,
database, calculator, prontbibliotheek
op betaalde nieuwsbrief rond een
specifieke nich. Gebruik TikTok,
Instagram, YouTube, LinkedIn of SEO om
gratis bereik op te bouwen.
Start-upkosten zijn laag en
verdienmodels op eenmalige verkopen of
abonnementen. Heel interessant. En wat
hij ook als laatste zegt is: "Als ik
vandaag helemaal vanaf nul zou beginnen,
zou mijn volgorde als volgd zijn:
service, cashflow, specialisatie,
automatisering, digitaal product. Dus
niet meteen een webshop, app of passief
inkomen proberen op te bouwen. Eerst een
probleem vinden waarvoor [muziek] iemand
nu al bereid is te betalen. Zodra dat
probleem zodra jij dat probleem goed
begrijpt, kun je een proces
automatiseren en uiteindelijk een
schalbaar product maken. Oké, dus
eigenlijk wat ChatGipt zegt is oké, ga
eerst ervoor zorgen dat je een bepaalde
service kan aanbieden aan een bedrijf of
in een bepaalde niche en [muziek] vanuit
daar dus eigenlijk je ervaring en kennis
en skills kan leren, zodat je dat
uiteindelijk kan productiseren. En dan
ben ik wel heel benieuwd, wat als ik
geen ervaring heb in deze service aan te
bieden, wat zou ik dan moeten doen? Dus
dat is de volgende vraag die ik aan hem
ga stellen. Oké, helder. Top dat we
moeten starten met een service. Alleen
ik heb totaal nog geen ervaring met
online business of überhaupt ondernemen.
Hoe kan ik die service dan het
makkelijkste en het beste aanbieden?
Laten we dit eens vragen. Want veel
mensen zijn natuurlijk helemaal nieuw in
het ondernemen, dus die weten nog
helemaal niks. Daarom zegt Chattier
juist: "Omdat je nog geen ervaringen
hebt, zou ik het simpel houden. [muziek]
Je hoeft niet eerst ondernemer te
worden. Je moet eerst leren é concreet
probleem voor één type klant op te
lossen. [muziek] De makkelijkste manier
om te beginnen, ik zou dit stappenplan
gebruiken. Niet ik help bedrijven met
AI, maar ik help lokale sportscholen om
een klantvragen automatisch af te
handelen. Kies één probleem. Dus
bijvoorbeeld veel dezelfde vragen via
WhatsApp, e-mail of afspraken die
halmatig ingepland kunnen worden. En
vervolgens zegt hij ook: "Maak één
simpel aanbod en leer een probleem
oplossen voordat je probeert te
verkopen." Nader vervolgens bedrijven
persoonlijk en dan geeft je ook een
template hoe je dat zou kunnen doen.
[muziek] En doe je eerste klant goedkoop
of met een pilot. Oké. Oké. En
belangrijk begin niet met AI. Dat is een
fout die veel beginners maken. Een klant
koopt niet AI automatisering, maar ik
wil minder tijd kwijt zijn aan leads
opvolgen. Oké, helder. Alleen ik heb
totaal nog geen ervaring met iets
verkopen of überhaupt ondernemen. Hoe
zou je als starter daarin dan je eerste
stappen kunnen maken? Ik ben heel
benieuwd wat hij hierop zegt, want dit
is wel echt een belangrijk puntje. Veel
mensen willen ondernemen en die willen
starten met hun eigen bedrijf. Zoals
hier Chat GPT zegt van: "Ja, ga starten
in de AI automatiseringen." Ja, heel
leuk. Alleen als je niet weet wat
verkopen is, dan is het natuurlijk heel
lastig. En daarop zegt Chat GPT het
volgende. Ik zou het in vier fases
aanpakken. Eerst leren verkopen zonder
meteen iets te verkopen. Begin met
observeren. Kijk naar bedrijven in een
niche [muziek] die je interessant vindt.
En vraag jezelf aan ieder bedrijf af:
waar verdienen ze geld mee? Waar
verliezen ze tijd? En waar komen klanten
vandaan? Oké, helder. Kies daarna
[muziek] een simpele vaardigheid. Als
beginner zou ik niet meteen proberen met
expert in AI te worden. Kies een
praktische vaardigheid die je
bijvoorbeeld 2 tot 4 weken behoorlijk
kunt leren. Denk aan AI workflows, short
form content, simpele websites maken en
maak vervolgens iets voor iemand het
koopt. Dit is een belangrijke stap. Stel
dat je besluit: "Ik wil bedrijven helpen
met AI automatiseringen, bouw dan
bijvoorbeeld voor jezelf een kleine
demo. Nieuwe klant, formulier, AI
analyseert.
En automatisch antwoord:
Ja, helder. En als vierde, je eerste
verkoopgesprek is eigenlijk gewoon een
gesprek. Oké, helder. En belangrijk, hoe
kom je dan uiteindelijk bij het geld?
Bijvoorbeeld je leert, je maakt een
demo, je praat met bedrijven, iemand
heeft interesse en je doet een kleine
pilot. Je levert resultaat, je vraagt
een testimonial en je verhoogt daarna je
prijs. Oké, klinkt op zich logisch, maar
ik vind het nog best lastig om dan naar
zo'n bedrijf toe te gaan en te gaan
verkopen. Hoe zou ik dit in een
laagdrempelige manier kunnen leren in
een bepaald business model of misschien
wel bij zo'n AI bedrijf? Zal ik
eigenlijk wat ervaring opdoe voordat ik
zelf mijn eigen product verkoop?
[muziek] Dit is vaak een hele goede
manier om voor starters aan de slag te
gaan. Stel je kan bij zo'n AI bedrijf de
verkoop leren, de marketing leren,
kijken hoe zij ehm ja, binnen hun
bedrijf dit eigenlijk opzetten, dan kan
je over een jaar bijvoorbeeld die stap
wel volledig voor jezelf maken. Dus
[muziek] ik zou heel eerlijk, nu ik zo
aan het sparren ben met CHGT, zou ik
eerder ervoor gaan om dat een keer bij
een ander bedrijf te zien en misschien
bij zo'n AI bedrijf te zien van heyé,
hoe regelen zij alles in en vanuit daar
pas eigenlijk voor mezelf te gaan.
Anders is het risico natuurlijk ook heel
groot. Dus ik ben benieuwd wat Chat GBT
zegt en wat hij van dit idee vindt. Eens
even [muziek] kijken. Hij zegt: "Sterker
nog, ik denk dat dit voor jou
waarschijnlijk een betere route is dan
meteen je eigen AI service proberen te
verkopen." [muziek] Je zoekt eigenlijk
een soort ondernemerschap met
zijwiiltjes.
Eerst ervaring op doen met sales,
klanten en AI terwijl iemand anders al
het product en infrastructuur heeft. Ik
zou kijken naar deze drie routes. Ga
werken bij een kleine AI SAA start-up,
mijn favoriet. Zoek bijvoorbeeld naar de
functies [muziek] sales development,
business development, executive, lastige
woorden, een customer success manager en
implementation en onboarding. Voor jou
zou ik SDR bij een kleine AI of SA
start-up bijzonder interessant kunnen
zijn. Waarom? Je leert daar precies wat
je zelf later nodig hebt. Prospects
vinden, contact leggen, behoefte
ontdekken, demo opmaken, bezwaren
behandelen, deal sluiten en een klant
behouden. En je krijgt ondertussen je
salaris terwijl je leert. Nog beter,
zoek een klein bedrijf van bijvoorbeeld
5 tot 50 mensen in plaats van alleen
naar een enorme corporate. Daar krijg je
vaak veel meer mee hoe het hele bedrijf
werkt. [muziek] Dit is eigenlijk precies
wat ik bedoelde. Je gaat niet direct je
eigen AI software of dienst of product
verkopen, want je weet nog helemaal niet
hoe dat proces ervoor gaat. Het is
slimmer om, zoals JGBD hier nu ook zegt
om als SDR, dus bijvoorbeeld sales
development representative om eerst die
verkoopgesprekken te leren voeren. Zoals
je hier ook ziet, nog steeds een salaris
of op basis van commissie betaald worden
op de deals die je maakt. En
tegelijkertijd ben je van binnenuit in
het bedrijf aan het leren hoe zij dit
soort verkopen doen, hoe zij dit soort
producten aanbieden en hoe zij überhaupt
business doen. Smer 2 zegt hij: "Ga
freelance werken voor een bestaande
agency. Dit is misschien nog
laagdrempeliger als je niet meteen een
baan wilt. Zoek bijvoorbeeld AI,
marketing automations of web agencies en
bied aan om hem te helpen met lead
zoeken, prospects benaderen, afspraken
inplannen, eenvoudige automatiseringen
bouwen, klanten onboorden of content
maken. Je hoeft niet zelf de klant te
vinden. Die agency heeft al die klanten
en jij leert achter de schermen hoe zo'n
servicebedrijf werkt. Dat kan
uiteindelijk enorm waardevol voor jou
zijn als jij over één of twee jaar die
stap als ondernemer wilt gaan zetten
omdat je eigenlijk betaald aan het leren
bent. Dat is wat chatupt zegt. En dat is
nummer drie: zoek een sales
apprenticeship bij jezelf. Als je geen
geschikte baan of agency kunt vinden,
kun je het gecontroleerd zelf leren. Dus
bijvoorbeeld leer de basis van sales.
Kies een AI service, maak een demo,
benader 10 bedrijven. Niet om direct te
verkopen, maar om gesprekken te voeren.
Je kunt jezelf een doel geven.
Bijvoorbeeld mijn eerste 10 gesprekken
zijn onderzoek en ik hoef niks te
verkopen. En dat haalt enorm de druk
weg. En dat is waar wat ChatBT zegt. Ik
ben het er heel erg mee eens [muziek]
dat je eerst bepaalde stappen en skills
moet opdoen zoals verkoop en zoals
marketing en zoals content voordat jij
je eigen bedrijf kan starten. En daarom
is het wel su slim om dat eerst dus bij
een agency of een AI bedrijf te doen die
deze leads toch al hebben en die deze
klanten toch al hebben. Je hoeft alleen
simpelweg deze klanten te gaan spreken
en ze te gaan sluiten, zodat je
gaandeweg bij zo'n bedrijf mee kan
kijken en kan leren hoe [muziek]
ondernemerschap in deze nich in elkaar
zit. Maar hij zegt: "Persoonlijk zou ik
voor route 1 gaan. Dus als je tegen mij
zou zeggen: "Ik heb nul ervaring. Ik
vind verkopen spannend en ik wil
uiteindelijk zelf een AI business
starten." Dan zou zijn advies zijn: ga 6
tot 12 maanden werken bij een kleine AI
SAAS start-up in een commerciële junior
rol. Je hoeft daar niet binnen te komen
als AI expert. Je verkoopt misschien een
software die al bestaat. En daardoor
hoef je niet tegelijkertijd en zelf een
product te bedenken en een dienst te
bouwen en klanten te zoeken en sales te
leren en facturen te sturen
tegelijkertijd. [muziek] Maar je kunt
één ding tegelijkertijd leren. Dus hoe
krijg ik iemand enthousiast genoeg om
geld te betalen voor de oplossing die
wij hebben als bedrijf zijnde? Dat is de
meest waardevolle vaardigheid die je als
ondernemer kunt hebben, zegt JPT.
[muziek]
En ondertussen kun je 's avonds rustig
experimenteren met je eigen ideeën. De
ideale combinatie is dan overdag leren,
verkopen voor iemand anders, 's avonds
leren bouwen met AI. Later beide
combineren in je eigen business. En wat
ik zelf zou doen, je hoeft niet eens je
baan op te zeggen. Je zou hier
bijvoorbeeld in de avonduren ook al voor
zo'n Saas AI agency aan de slag kunnen
gaan. al op basis van commissie betaald
kunnen krijgen en niet per se per uur
overdag omdat je natuurlijk ook gewoon
je normale 9 tot vif baanen hebt. Ga
gewoon in de avond watsappen erbij
nemen. Ga leren over verkopen. Ga leren
over hoe je zo'n bedrijf opbouwt.
[muziek] En deze gesprekken met de
klanten dus ook te voeren. En op deze
manier kan je naast je baan zonder dat
je die zekerheid verliest van je
loonstrook. Die krijg je gewoon nog elke
maand.
[muziek]
Ga je in de avond gewoon wat bijbeunen?
Ga je gewoon wat extra erbij doen bij
zo'n AI bedrijf zoals JPT zegt waarin je
die gesprekken kan gaan leren, waarin je
verkoop kan gaan leren. Wat Chat Jippt
ook zegt dat dit [muziek] de
waardevolste skill is als ondernemer
zijnde het kunnen verkopen van je
product of dienst en vanuit daar je
overstap over 6 of 12 maanden te kunnen
nemen naar volledig je eigen bedrijf. En
hij zegt ook: "Dit is naar mijn mening
een veel minder engere opstap dan morgen
bij 20 bedrijven binnenlopen dat je je
eigen AI service hebt." En het is
logisch wat hij zegt. Je moet gewoon
eerst leren in de praktijk bij zo'n
bedrijf hoe verkoop werkt, hoe content
werkt, hoe een team aansturen werkt.
Want dit is allemaal nieuw voor je. En
vanuit daar kan je dus je eerste stappen
nemen als ondernemer zijn. Oké, helder.
Dus eigenlijk wat je zegt is dat ik bij
een AI agency of iets van een bedrijf
[muziek] moet gaan leren hoe verkoop
werkt, hoe content werkt en hoe
marketing werkt. En vanuit daar
eigenlijk mijn allereerste stap als
ondernemer kan maken. Alleen hoe kom ik
in dit wereldje? Hoe kom ik bij bij die
bedrijven terecht? Ook een hele
relevante vraag, want ja, je bent net
nieuw, hoe ga je die bedrijven vinden?
En dat is natuurlijk wel een dingetje.
En daarop zegt JPT het volgende. Ja, ik
zou het [muziek] net iets anders
aanpakken dan alleen ik zoek een AI
agency en solliciteer. Je wilt jezelf
positioneren als iemand die heel graag
wil leren hoe AI plus sales plus
business werkt. Ik heb even gekeken naar
de huidige markt in Nederland en er zijn
daadwerkelijk startersrollen die hier
goed op aansluiten. [muziek] Zo staat er
bijvoorbeeld een SDR BDR startersfunctie
in SAAS en AI in Amsterdam waarin
expliciet wordt aangegeven dat je als
starter kunt beginnen en leert prospect
teen benaderen, afspraken inplannen en
de sales pipeline opbouwen. En ook zijn
er in Nederland duizenden SDR vacatures
met tientallen tot honderden vacatures
voor instapniveau. [muziek] Oké, dus er
zijn heel veel vacatures open. Alleen
wat als ik overdag gewoon nog mijn
loondienstbanen heb? Kan ik dit wel
daarnaast doen? En daarop zegt JTI het
volgende: maar ik zou dan niet meteen
een tweede baan bij een AI bedrijf
nemen. Als je een fulltime baan hebt,
wordt het al snel teveel en je wilt het
juiste manier vinden om dit rustig op te
bouwen. Ik zou onderscheid maken tussen
drie routes. [muziek] Één, een paar uur
per week meedraaien bij een start-up
agency. Dit kan interessant zijn als een
bedrijf open staat voor part-time
freelance of commissionbased rol.
bijvoorbeeld 5 tot 10 uurtjes per week
waarin je gaat leads zoeken, LinkedIn
outreach, salescs bijwonen, content
helpen maken, AI workflows leren bouwen
en meekijken met klantprojecten.
Je leert dan hetzelfde vak, maar zonder
je huidige inkomen direct op te geven.
Ik zou dit eigenlijk als allereerste
optie pakken. Waarschijnlijk heb je
gewoon je vaste kosten. Je hebt
natuurlijk gewoon je auto, je moet naar
je werk, je moet eten en de rekeningen
lopen gewoon [muziek] door. Dus ik zou
zeker ook naar zoiets kijken van oké hoe
kan ik met 5 tot 10 uurtjes per week
toch net even wat extra's doen en
bijvoorbeeld op een wat chatbt ook zegt
van heyé commission based rol iets doen
zodat je daarin gewoon in die avonduren
net één wat bij kan verdienen maar ook
twee de vaardighiden dus opdoet zoals
lead zoeken zoals salescast bijwonen en
zoals content helpen maken zodat jij
jezelf kan ontwikkelen als ondernemer
[muziek] zijnde
Want dit zijn allemaal vaardigheden voor
de toekomst. Bijvoorbeeld content maken.
Content is een supermooie manier van
marketing. Bijvoorbeeld lied zoeken.
Super belangrijk als ondernemer zijn om
te kunnen en salescals bijwonen.
Tegenwoordig gaat toch alleen maar meer
dingen online gebeuren. Dus hoe beter
jij online sales calls kunt gaan voeren,
hoe beter jij jezelf neerzet als
ondernemer zijn.
En hier zegt Jippt ook heel eerlijk: "Ik
zou gewoon je huidige baan voorlopig
gewoon lekker houden." Je hebt op dit
moment namelijk één enorm voordeel. Je
hoeft nog geen geld te verdienen met je
onderneming. [muziek] Dat geeft je
vrijheid om fouten te maken. Stel dat je
€0 verdient in maand 1, €100 in maand 2
en 400 in maand 3, dat is helemaal prima
zolang je huidige salaris gewoon
hetzelfde blijft. Dus dan is het alleen
maar een extraatje tijdens dat je deze
vaardigheden aan het leren bent.
Daardoor kun je ook experimenteren
zonder de druk van ik moet volgende
maand mijn huur betalen met mijn
start-up. Dus hij geeft ook een ideale
route voor ons. En dit is het gameplan
van Chat GBT. Hij zou het ongeveer zo
doen. Naast zijn huidige baan 5 tot 8
uurtjes per week leren en [muziek]
experimenteren. Vervolgens eerst de
kleine AI service opzetten. Eerste €100
verdienen. Dan [muziek] eerste €500 per
maand verdienen en dan beslissen wil ik
een eigen business of wil ik overstappen
naar AI of SAAS. Eventueel huidige baan
afbouwen is de volgende stap. Maar eerst
die vaardigheden opdoen, zodat je
überhaupt als ondernemer kunt gaan
groeien.
Oké, helder. En je hebt het over
verkopen en sales et cetera. [muziek]
Zijn er ook nog manieren om sneller
zoiets te leren of is de enige manier om
dit te leren echt bij een ander bedrijf?
Dat is de volgende vraag die ik best wel
relevant vind van ja, moet het echt via
zo'n bedrijf of zijn er ook andere
manieren? Daarom zegt Chat GPT: "Nee,
bij een ander bedrijf is één manier,
[muziek] maar zeker niet de enige." En
als je doel specifiek is om snel beter
te worden in sales, zou ik juist
meerdere manieren combineren. [muziek]
De snelste combinatie: leer de basis in
een paar dagen. Je hoeft geen
maandenlang theorie te doen. Leer
bijvoorbeeld hoe je een prospect vindt,
hoe je je eerste bericht schrijft, hoe
je goede vragen stelt en hoe je
behoeftes ontdekt. En hij geeft je ook
deze prompt die je kan geven aan ChatGPT
om te gaan oefenen met dit soort
gesprekken. Dus doe alsof je de eigenaar
bent van een marketingbureau. Ik probeer
de AI automatisering te verkopen en we
voeren een realistisch verkoopgesprek.
[muziek] Geef niet meteen toe en werp
normale bezwaren op. Interessant. Daarna
doe je het gesprek opnieuw en vraag je
feedback op. je vragen, je
luistervaardigheden, je pitch, [muziek]
je bezwarenbehandeling
en momenten waarop je teveel aan het
praten was. Interessant. Vervolgens zegt
hij: "Ga daar ga daarna de echte wereld
in." Dus hier gebruik je de echte
versnelling. 10 gesprekken, feedback,
aanpassen en 10 nieuwe gesprekken
voeren. Heel interessant wat hij hier
zegt. Dus eigenlijk wat hij zegt is: "Ga
[snuift] aan de slag met theorie, ga
oefenen met rollenspellen met Chat GBT."
Je kan dit soort gesprekken dus
letterlijk al met je GBT gaan oefenen.
En vervolgens zegt hij: "Oké, ga daarna
gewoon aan de slag met echte gesprekken
[muziek] en echte ondernemers." En hij
zegt ook: "Ik kan je helpen met een
concreet 30 dagen plan om sales leren
vanaf nul op te stellen." Nou, daar ben
ik wel benieuwd naar. Kijken waar die
mee komt.
Top. Dan zou ik het vooral praktisch en
herhaalbaar naast je baan maken. Je doel
na 30 dagen is niet dat je een geweldige
verkoper bent, maar dat je zonder enorme
drempel een ondernemer kunt aanspreken,
[muziek]
een goed gesprek kunt voeren en een
probleem kunt herkennen waar iemand
mogelijk voor wil betalen.
Je 30dagen plan, 30 tot 45 minuutjes per
dag. Nou, op zich makkelijk te doen in
de avonduren die je toch over hebt.
Begrijpen hoe sales werkt is week é.
Daarna oefenen zonder risico. Dus dan
met chat GPT oefenen en vervolgens echte
ondernemers spreken. Dit wordt
interessant. Je gaat nog niet proberen
iets te verkopen. [muziek]
Zoek bijvoorbeeld 10 tot 20 ondernemers
in de sector die je interessant vindt.
Bijvoorbeeld zo'n AI niche. Ik ben
momenteel aan het verdiepen in AI en
sales. [muziek] Ik probeer vooral beter
te begrijpen wat de praktive problemen
van ondernemers zijn. zou je misschien
[muziek] 10 minuutjes wat vragen kunnen
stellen. En week 3: echt
ondernemerspreken. Hierin geeft chat GPT
ook een heel gameplan en een berichtje
die je naar ondernemers zou kunnen
sturen om je allereerste rol te landen.
En vervolgens week 4er van gesprek naar
eerste aanbod. Nu kun je terug gaan
kijken naar de gesprekken. Stel dat je
bijvoorbeeld drie ondernemers spreekt en
allemaal zeggen ze: "We krijgen veel
leads, maar de opvolging schiet er soms
bij in." Dan weet je dus dat je daarvoor
een eh automatisering kan gaan bouwen of
je eigen diensten en je eigen
verkoopskills die je zojuist hebt
opgedaan aan te bieden aan zo'n
ondernemer, zodat je binnen die teams
aan de slag kan. En na die 30 dagen zegt
Chat JBT ook: "Oké, nu kun je gaan
kiezen." [muziek]
Na die 30 dagen heb je eigenlijk drie
mogelijke richtingen. Één, je vindt
sales geweldig. Dus je zoekt een
part-time start-up sales rol of gaat
meelopen bij een agency. Twee. Ik vind
AI bouwen interessanter. Verdiep je in
de automation en bouw je eigen service.
Of drie, je vindt allebei leuk. En dit
is waarschijnlijk de interessantste
combinatie. AI en kunnen verkopen en je
eigen service hebben. Ja, dan bestaat er
geen mogelijkheid dat jij niet succesvol
wordt in het ondernemen. Want als je
verkoop leuk vindt en de dienst die je
aanbiedt leuk vindt, dan ga je 100%
slagen. En dat is ook wat chatbt hier
zegt. Je hoeft nu nog niet helemaal te
weten welke drie het wordt. De komende
drie dagen zijn juist bedoeld om
daarachter te komen. Dus als ik dit zo
helemaal samenvat, dan [muziek] zijn de
top drie niches die ChatGPT zou zeggen
om te starten als online ondernemer. AI,
verkoop en. [muziek]
En wat chatbt dus zegt is: "Ga niet in
één keer je eigen product en dienst
aanbieden." Nee, wat hij zegt is: "Hey,
kijk naar bijvoorbeeld een remote sales
rol. Kijk naar hoe je binnen zo'n
bedrijf al content kan gaan leren of
marketing kan gaan leren of het verkopen
van deze AI producten kan gaan leren.
Zodat je tijdens dat je betaald wordt
ben je de skills aan het leren als
ondernemer zijnde. Dus verkoop,
marketing en AI. En als je hier
inmiddels wat maandjes mee bezig bent
geweest, dan ben je erachter gekomen van
heyé, is ondernemerschap wat voor mij?
Vind ik sales misschien geweldig? Vind
ik AI automation bouwen geweldig? En
misschien vind je beide wel geweldig en
dat je daar je business van maakt. Maar
wat JGBT ook zegt is zonder dat je wat
dingen probeert [muziek] ga je er nooit
echt achterkomen wat voor jou het beste
is. Dus eigenlijk is er maar één ding om
vanuit hier te doen en dat is gewoon
actie nemen. Verkoopgesprekken via chat
GBT gaan proberen te leren. Ga je
verdiepen in sales? Ga je verdiepen in
verkoop. En vergeet ook niet te
abonneren op mijn kanaal als je dit
soort video's tof vindt en als het je
geholpen heeft om je allereerste stap
richting online ondernemerschap te
zetten. Want ik vind het enorm tof om
anderen hiermee te helpen, mijn jongeren
zelf te helpen met een online inkomen te
genereren. Want ik kan je vertellen als
je er eenmaal eentje hebt dan wil je
nooit meer terug. Dan ga ik je bedanken
voor het kijken. Dit was hem voor
vandaag en dan zie ik je in de volgende.